HARSH PUNISHMENT FOR THE
SOLDIER'S COMMANDER, WHO
ANALYSTS SAY COULD BE EXECUTED.
>> A NORTH KOREAN SOLDIER IN HIS
LATE TEENS MAKES A DARING E
ESCAPE.
MOST OF THE DMZ IS GUARDED BY
MINE FEELS, TALL FENCES WITH
RAIDER WIRE, GUARD POSTS.
ANALYSTS SAY THE AREA IN WHICH
THIS SOLDIER CROSSED IS LESS
FORTIFIED.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS, THE
SOLDIER SAID HE LEFT BECAUSE OF
WIDESPREAD BEATINGS AND ABUSE.
>> THE NORTH KOREAN MILITARY IS
RENOUNCE FOR HARSH DISCIPLINE
A
AND.
HE WOULD BE BEAT SIMPLY BY JUST
LOOKING ASKANCE AT AN OFFICER.
THERE'S NO RESTRAINT AT ALL.
>> TONY SHAFFER, WHO ONCE RAN
OPERATION IN THAT AREA, SAYS THE
DEFECTOR CAN GIVE THE U.S. AND
SOUTH KOREAN MILITARY ON PLACES
WHERE THE NORTH KOREANS
ROUTINELY INSERT SAEB TOURS, BUT
THERE WILL BE CONSEQUENCES FOR
THE SOLDIER'S FAMILY.
>> YOU CAN'T EXPECT A POTENTIAL
LITERAL SUMMARY ASSASSINATION OF
HIS FAMILY.
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
NORTH KOREANS ALWAYS MAKE SURE
THAT ANYONE WHO CONTEMPLATES
DEFECTION WILL BE UNDERSTANDS.
>> Reporter: IT COULD TARGET
MOUNTAIN PAUL GENERATIONS,
LIKELY HIS PARENTS AND
GRANDPARENTS.
ALONG WITH OTHER AGGRESSIVE
MOVES LIKE TEST FIRING ANTISHIP
MISSILES, KIM JONG-UN HAS
CRACKED DOWN ON DEFECTORS,
TIGHTENING PATROLS ALONG THE
CHINESE BORDER.
>> THIS IS EMBARRASSING FOR THE
NORTH KOREAN REGIME, BECAUSE IT
COMPLETELY CRACKS THE MYTH OF
HOW THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE A
PARADISE, A SOCIETY IN WHICH
EVERYBODY IS